this is a production of Cornell
University so I'm really happy to be
here I have to say this is not an
invited talk that I wanted to do it and
I asked yulian if I could and so she
said yes so I'm really very delighted to
be here and what you might want to ask
is is there more than one I toss very
interested and I'd say the answer is yes
my thesis in this seminar will be to
convince you that there are dramatically
different versions of this organism and
let's see another question I think we
should address is does it matter if
there is more than one version of this
organism as Ellen alluded it turns out
that this idea is not popular and maybe
it's inconvenient but I will illustrate
toward the end of the seminar how
unpopular this idea is a minute my
organization is listed here on the
screen now Kathy Hodge told me that I
had to introduce the pathogen and
indicate why it's important so Kathy for
you I'm going to do that you've seen
some of these slides before and then I'm
going to talk about my labs motivation
for addressing this question we look at
some differences and then we'll look at
some more differences and then we'll
look at some of the implications so
first I want to start off by described
with the asexual cycle of itopf third
fest ends and this is again many of you
know this already this is a sporangia
if place under cool conditions and in
the presence of water ZOA spores can be
produced from this branch um here's a
schematic of one it's hard to get a
picture of a swims or because they're
swimming if it lands on a leaf it can
produce a lesion like this
and that's about a two or three day old
lesion within a couple days those
lesions expand overnight there could be
massive sporulation from those lesions
if you look at them under the second
scope as some of you might do so in the
field this is what they look like you
can see this brandy among the trichomes
of potatoes and this is a microscopic
view of these its branches they are air
early this first and so these spreads
you can be convened phone in the air or
splash dispersed and they can survive in
the atmosphere for some hours but I
think really important is that this
whole cycle can take about five or six
days a single sporangium can give rise
to a huge number of others brandy here -
we've measured up to 300,000 speranza
from the single lesion so the
reproductive potential of this organism
is really important and as a result you
can turn a field of healthy-looking
potatoes like this in seven or eight
days to something that looks like that
- something that looks like this and
another seven or eight days so those are
real pictures of real epidemics that I
took and observed so this organism is
really important it also has a sexual
cycle there are two mating types a 1 and
a 2 and the OS pores are the long-lived
spores that survive they can survive in
soil for many years it turns out in
nature or in agriculture there are only
two places in the world now where the
sexual cycle occurs one is in central
Mexico and the other is in the
Scandinavian countries and MIT perhaps
other parts of northwest Europe and as
Alan mentioned we've known about this
organism for a long time I've worked on
it all my career my mother used to say
well bill have you solved the problem
yet I can you know if he asked that
question
I'm and again I said well no mom not not
yet toward the you know later on she
stopped asking that question but I'm not
alone there are a lot of us who have not
solved it yet it first appeared in the
United States in 1843 first appeared in
Europe in 1845 and as Ellen said it
caused the famine in Ireland in from
1845 for the next really quite a few
years I think it originated in central
Mexico and the highlands in central
Mexico probably came first to the US and
then to Europe and then from Europe it
went all the rest of the world it went
on infected seed tubers potatoes are
planted from tubers those tubers can get
infected and it turns out that northwest
Europe is a great place to grow seed
tubers and they are transported all
around the world and that's how this
organism gets around it's remarkably
effective at at going worldwide it is
Ellen also mentions still problem we
estimate six billion dollars a year
annually in losses and control costs and
more than 3,000 articles annually on
this disease many of them in the pump in
the refereed literature but some are not
and that's because it causes a disease
in agriculture is the reason that it's
important I'm going to give three quick
examples from my experience of why this
is an important pathogen this is a
picture taken
actually my mother-in-law sent this to
me she lives south at Utica the picture
taken in 1995 of the Harold American
from Utica it's a picture of Byron
Chapman who the year before had lost his
entire crop to late blight new strain
had come in it had devastated these
fields and he sent me these data
indicating the magnitude of the loss
that he experienced you notice he says
he had a million dollars in losses
he will not grow potatoes in 1995 his
crops
destroyed in 1994 not only did he not
grow potatoes in 1995 but he declared
bankruptcy and he actually died a couple
years after this photo was taken some of
you might remember this one this is 2009
there was a major pandemic of late
blight on tomatoes in up and down they
actually the the East Coast and it
caused a lot of problems because
previously late blight on tomatoes had
been not so problematic but it got a lot
of people upset in the Northeast in 2009
this is an email I got from one of those
persons who said she was an organic
grower she had 23 different varieties
they're all gone she had to leave home
as her husband is pulling in bagging all
sixty three plants they had a hundred
percent loss she was planning to sell
tomatoes for an additional source of
income and my third example concerns
another lineage this is blue 13 it
originated somewhere in northwest Europe
it also has gone all over the world it
in 2014
caused a terrible epidemic in West Bend
all the previous strains that had been
there we're not so severe blue 13 was
very aggressive
it was resistant to a dominant fungicide
monoxide more minimal it was highly
virulent and it infected both potatoes
and tomatoes so just three examples that
late blood is still a real important
problem so but I want to describe next
is my motivation for addressing this
question will the real fight tougher
infest hands make itself known and this
is a question that my lab has been sort
of toying with for the last 20 years we
attempted to get it funded but that was
never successful but I'll tell you why
we started investigating it and I'm
going to look a lot of this as FRA lab
failures these are some field
experiments
that we did some years ago so there's a
failure in each one of these experiments
and I'm going to describe the failure in
this one but you can see at the end of
the season is that are some plants that
are healthy and there are some plants
that are dead and what this experiment
among other things was attempting to do
was to investigate the role of Oz mutton
now this paper appeared in PNAS in 1994
it says the Ozma ttan overexpression and
potato delays development of disease
symptoms in late life that's fantastic
here's a transgenic approach I contacted
the authors they sent me their
transgenic potatoes we planted those and
compared them with the non-transgenic
and unfortunately this is the result the
plants were not resistant we could
measure no resistance in those
transgenics so this is one of our first
you know they saw them resistance in the
lab we could not see it in the field a
second one example occurred somewhat
later and this result from a colleague
in Europe who wrote me and it was really
interesting she said I've created
resistance lately I said wow that's
really neat she licensed the technology
to a company and then lo and behold they
showed up in the US because they wanted
to sell transgenic resistant potatoes in
the US they couldn't do it in Europe
because of GMO attitudes there so as we
said yeah great let's do it and so this
is a picture of that experiment there
are about a hundred different transgenic
events or transformative events in this
this experiment with lots and lots and
lots of replications
I think the trends the technology was
that there was a pathogen specific motor
linked to an our gene and an AVR gene
the idea being that when the pathogen
contacted the cell
it would activate this cassette and you
need HR and you'd get resistance makes
sense right
so apparently that that's what was
licensed and this is the result of that
experiment there everything died there
was a little diversity I have to say but
there was absolutely no effect of the
transgenders so we did see some
diversity when you put potatoes through
a callus and you get you release a lot
of some fungal variation and we did see
that we saw nothing that we could
attribute to the transgenders
I thought again was really interesting
so the question I've asked is why can't
we not see in the field things that
other people can see in the lab and I
think the answer is this that the
sporangia from a plate culture are
different from this brand G that come
from an infective leaflet the reason I
think that is that we had previously
seen some suggestions the first
suggestion came with work done by
Eduardo Meza booty and Eduardo's
interest was in the sensitivity of
sporangia to solar radiation and Eduardo
had a tough summer um he was getting
spraying from plate he'd expose them to
sunlight and absolutely everything died
they didn't survive at all one time when
he didn't have a culture from the plate
ready
he took sporangia from a leaflet exposed
them to solar radiation and lo and
behold some of them survived
so that turn so all the rest of his
experiments then we're done with
spraying G that came from elisa
so there is so this brand gia from a
culture plate are very sensitive to
solar radiation this brand
from a lesion are much less sensitive to
silver radiation so that's one
difference another came from work we
collaborated with with Dan classic at
BTI
Dan was interested in arachidonic acid
stimulating resistance in potatoes and
we gave him an isolated fi tosser and
festoons and these are small images but
you can see that if there was no
arachidonic acid applied to the plant
there was a good sized lesion if
arachidonic acid was applied to to the
plant then there was a really tiny leaf
great paddy Manesh album published that
the problem came with a couple years
later whom we tried to repeat some of
that work we got the following result
and we got the result because we took
our sporangia from a leaflet and this is
what we have obtained there was
absolutely no effect of the arachidonic
acid if we took this branch of tin plate
we did the experiment properly we had
this control and we got that result that
if we took those Ranjha from a plate
then we saw the effect of arachidonic
acid if we took the sporangia from a
leaflet we did not see the effect of
arachidonic acid so that caused us to
begin to look at the differences between
sporangia that are produced on a plate
versus sporangia that are produced on a
leaflet and from
describe next to some of Shawn Patty's
master's thesis work so the first essay
that we did was to look at pathogenicity
of sprage it come from a plate versus
pranchi that come from leaflet and he
did the work first of all in the field
plots using two different isolates for
isolate one he found if they if this
brand you came from a plate he got 12%
disease in the field for isolate one if
the spread you came from a leaflet he
got 35% now it turned out that Iceland
had only been only two passages inter
culture if he looked at I slit two which
had been on a plate for at least nine
passages he found 3% disease versus 52%
disease so there's quite a bit more
disease resulting from the same number
of sporangia depending on whether the
spores come from if there's little
disease if they come from a plate
lots more disease if they come from a
leaflet LeSean repeated this experiment
in a moist chamber and he found somewhat
similar results for isolate 127 percent
first branch from a plate 80 percent
disease for sporangia from a leaflet for
isolate two that had nine passages he
found an even greater difference one
percent if this branch came from a plate
and 87 percent if this branch came from
elisa so clearly there are differences
in the aggressiveness of sprint at
coming from place or leaflet it's
interesting to me to note that four
inoculations that are done in the
literature the concentration of spur
energy in a medium can have is a
three-fold of schools and three orders
of magnitude difference sometimes there
are hundreds per of spraying per mill
particularly from our lab and sometimes
there are a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand three hundred thousand four
hundred thousand five hundred thousand
sporangia per mil in inoculation and
my thought was you know they probably
use a hundred thousand sporangia if they
need them and they would use fewer
frangie if you if they didn't need the
the huge numbers that's never said in
the paper but that's a conclusion that
one can draw and then Sean also did some
gene expression studies he took spraying
from plates spraying her from leaflets
and he did applied those to RNA seek a
little there's a little bit about the
genome effect off infest hands they're
more than 240 mega bases in the genome
seventy-five percent of the genome is
repetitive DNA there are more than
17,000 genes and in this analysis we
found more than 15,000 genes with our
reads per kilobase of exon model per
million base mapped reads so those are
the ones that we can detect oil via how
am i doing sunshine is that right
okay so our bioinformatics is sitting
right there so we did detect a fair
number of those genes and what was just
furbling me away were these data is that
in the isolate of Phytophthora infestans
which had nine passages on a plate there
were four thousand seven hundred ninety
one significant differentially expressed
genes and as comparing a plate sporangia
to leaflets pradya for the is't that had
only two passages in pure culture there
were 2,000 155 significant
differentially expressed genes again
comparing plate to leaflet together
there were almost 5,400 significant digs
comparing plate sporangia to leaflet
sporangia there were
for these two isolates there were 1549
network shared significant
differentially expressed genes of those
1544 were especially in the same
direction these are all up or all down
so there are five that were not that's a
discrepancy rate of about 0.003 percent
it's interesting also that there were
almost equal numbers of genes that were
upregulated versus downregulated in
these two different strengths in this
comparison so both up regulation and
down regulation we looked at the our XLR
effectors of which there are more than
550 in the genomic PM fast hands and we
detected 350 with an RP km greater than
one a hundred seventy of those were
significant differentially expressed
genes that is they were over-represented
compared to the whole genome as a to the
rest of the genome as a whole and there
were both upregulated and downregulated
so there's tremendous diversity in the
our XLR effectors our XLR effectors are
thought to be involved in pathogen this
the in fact our infest hands so some of
them we know to be recognized by our
genes
the vast majority we don't know what
they do and I think also important is
that there were no such effectors that
were down regulated in one eye slit and
up regulated in the other so they were
always in the same direction for both
isolates so we had these pathogenicity
differences which I think we're really
solid
we had these many digs and
so we submitted a paper to MPN I as a
technical advance because I think it's
important for people to know the
phenotypic characteristics of the
organism that they're working on and
then in August 19 2017 we got this
response that our manuscript has been
denied publication I find this part to
be really discouraged when I hope the
outcome of this specific submission
we're not discouraging for further
submissions
maybe else beside me have that reaction
so my initial reaction was this that you
know how could they be so stupid but
right now I actually talked with Alan
about it so I went back and read the
read the comments there's one that was
nice it was an interesting study and the
study did not explain underlying
mechanism that's true and then there was
this my principle methodological
methodological concern is that I would
like to see more information on direct
and indirect germination behavior this
branch here that's a reasonable request
then there was another the paper has a
major technical flaw the comparisons
were made between sporangia from
leaflets at five to six days post
inoculation and from r.i.p media at ten
to twelve days after inoculation is so
they had different ages of this branch
actually that's not a valid comment but
I had to address it and then I found the
analysis of differentially expressed
genes to be a little show had to agree
with that one too
so these are the objections not enough
on indirect germination they just branch
her there's insufficient analysis so now
back to the lab bench and here I'm going
to thank Kevin Myers who did a lot of
the next bits of work Kevin but doing
this was really fun I have to tell you
Kevin and I had a wonderful time in the
lab year ago because we're getting all
of these very interesting results so the
comment about indirection indirect
termination that's an absolutely valid
comment so we looked at indirect
termination
and lo and behold that if you takes
branch if from a plate you get three ten
eight eight percent indirect termination
if you take them from a leaf it seventy
nine forty sixty eighty one is for
different experiments searching huge
effect just really a huge effect so the
plates print you germinate a lot less
than that could be a factor then we had
to look at the age of this brand you um
the the reviewers correctly used Spanish
from a plate that was twelve days post
transfer or six to seven days from a
leaflet days bus inoculation and so we
looked at sprays that came from six to
seven day old place versus sprage that
came from six to seven day old leaflets
after inoculation that is and these are
the results we got exactly the same
phenomenon there was no effect of age
but sporangia that came from leaflet
germinate in directly at very high rates
sprayer that come from plates germinate
indirectly at very low rates so you know
i thought that sort of confirmed our
initial title that sprang geo
Phytophthora infestans produced from the
leaflet lesions differ from sporangia
produced from a naka me my to me and
we're just confirming what we had
initially said i wanted to show these
data in a slightly different way and
this again i have two kept thank heaven
pork there's another way to look at
indirect germination and that is to look
at the number of ZOA spores per
sporangia and kevin did this and again
the difference is absolutely huge if the
source port if the sporangia come from a
plate the number of ZOA spores per
sporangia m-- is very very low
if sporangia come from a leaflet the
number of ZOA spores per sporangia m--
is about a hundred fold greater so there
is a really big difference does that
explain the difference in
janessa tea for this these two types of
sporangia how can one address that based
on sporangia and we can do that what
else
yes well actually we don't have data on
direct termination but we can prevent
indirect termination if if we harvest
inoculate and incubate sporangia at 21
degrees that prevents indirect
termination
yes sir Adam direct termination is when
the sporangia m-- your bacteriologist I
mean really direct termination is when
the Spring Jam produces a germ tube and
that happens at about temperatures above
20 degrees indirect germination is when
this Varangian produces azoospermia
temperature we could prevent indirect
termination which in fact we did the
results of three different experiments
with it with an isolate of two to four
passages on on plates and if you look at
these experiment to see that the number
of so as far as perspiration is really
tiny consistent with what we saw
previously when we saw the disease they
got the same results essentially if this
branch
from a plate we get a certain amount of
disease if they come from earlier that
we get three four or five times more
disease that was consistent with all
these the second experiment here about
three to fold greater disease the third
experiment tenfold greater disease what
Kevin did in which I was really
delighted with is that what he then he
looked at the number of sporangia they
were produced on the leaflets that we
had an awfully and what you see here is
that and we normalize that to the amount
of disease present so what you see here
is that number of Springs are produced
from a plate about a thousand number of
spread Jia produced from a leaflet per
unit disease was fifteen thousand
experiment to about a thousand or almost
thirty thousand and experiment three
actually got no sporangia but about
sixteen thousand persons so not only do
those does that organism is it less
infective but the lesion that it
produces produces many fewer sporangia
probably less than ten percent as much
that was a difference I had not expected
I don't know if Kevin had expectancy it
but it was you know steep to the plate
let me get to that in just a bit the
question was have we ever added a magic
potion from leaves to the plate no but
let me I'll get back to that okay so
what we found us
termination is much less from plate
sporangia if we prevent indirect
termination we get much less sporulation
as well as less disease there is no
effect of this branch yeah and so our
next task was to try to look at the
amount of analysis that we didn't do so
we looked at the genes that were
significantly differentially expressed
that had flagellum somewhere in the name
there were 24 such genes detected 14
were digs 9 were detected in both and
these are those 9 and what you notice is
that they are all in the same direction
that is the expression of those genes in
this branch prone plate is dramatically
less than the expression of those genes
in us brand-new from leaflet that makes
sense right
we then looked at illicit ins now
illicit n't you own or ten kiloton
proteins that are produced by
Phytophthora species they do bind
sterols their exact function in plants
is really not known and you know that if
you inject them into leaflets you get HR
right we detected 41 with an RP km
greater than 119 of these weird eggs and
there were ten that word eggs in both
strains do you see here and envy there
and so this illustrates the difference
between plate and leaflets around you
the fold change and what you notice is
that nine of these are dramatically more
highly expressed in this Ferengi a--from
place than they are from leaflets one is
traumatically less expressed in
sporangia from plates and in leaflets
that's that's an interesting ELISA
tonight thing but these others are all
associated with production in in plates
we then look at the highest expression
the top 40 genes
and again the plate versus leaflet the
full change what I wanted to illustrate
these these these are the ones the most
highly expressed in plates the ones with
a green background 3 11 22 and 27
represent sugar or soggy transport which
is probably consistent with working on
growing on a medium that contains a lot
of sugar which they did there are four
genes that are typical of of stress
response the transferase nitrate we
deduct A's to heat shock proteins there
is one our XLR effector which is
interesting and there are two elicit ins
in four which is pretty famous and one
that has not yet been worked on so that
was a really interesting development and
then the next is that we looked at those
with the lowest expression the bottom
forty which means they were really
highly expressed in leaflets and
interesting to this there was four genes
that look like they were involved in
signaling there were two are XLR
effectors that were very highly
expressed and there was another gene
that was very highly expressed it has to
do with indirect termination this was as
been previously published by Howard
jettisons lab so it seemed to me that we
had done our work on indirect
termination no effect
excuse me large effects Agis French had
nothing to do it that Emily had done
some additional analysis so I thought
surely you know I'm gonna submit this
paper and it'll be just funny we
submitted it little less than a year ago
and then on June 29th I got this message
back which said this version of your
management has been denied publication
in molecular plant microbe interactions
again I crazy right we hadn't done
everything that the reviewers had said
so then I'm gonna show you next two
comments from this second said their
different set of reviewers this time on
the first
so the method that our authors used to
harvest this branch you might have
contributed difference so what the
reviewer says was suggested when we rub
the plate to get the syringe off the
plate we got nutrients which would
prevent indirect germination and
completely actually cited the wrong
supporting article for this so I did the
experiment and I rubbed a plate without
spread you put that on the leaflet and
pulled that off and I had no effect so
that is a bogus comment and then the
same reviewers had usually eye slits at
PFS those were maintained in the dark it
is true that some investigators keep
isolates of pea infest ends in the dark
that ain't what happens in nature
actually there's a diurnal phase in
nature but anyway we did the experiment
we kept him in the dark or or at an
alternating photo period and there was a
Zippo effect you know did not eliminate
that effect and this one I really love
he says as we know these branches from
lethal lesions were stressed by host
immunity you know that's not what the
RNA data said the RNA seek data said
that the ones that were stressed came
from the plates which I thought was so
the dogma here is real and so this is I
think the inconvenient truth that Ellen
was describing is that the height of the
spraying here from leaflets were
actually not stressed so I then wrote to
John McDowell at Virginia Tech how
happens that John McDowell is the
editor-in-chief of M PMI and so I'm
asking can you give me some advice on a
manuscript that I submitted etc etc then
I said I know the manuscript is
controversial but despite the
controversial nature the data are really
tight and I
to him about the bogus nature of the
comments from this second set of
reviewers I did it nicely
we had some email discussion then he
agreed that he would be a reviewer of
another version so I sent off the
version on September 21 and finally from
the senior editor the reviewers have
recommended publication so this this
paper is in press
this is figure 2 from that paper and it
it really describes the differences if
sporangia come from a plate indirect
termination is lower flagellar jeans are
lower pathogenicity joan elicit ins are
up and stress responses up if the spray
and you come from a leaflet indirect
terminations up flagellar jeans are up
pathogenicity is up you loose it to
insert a large you down and the stress
response is down what is the real
Phytophthora infestans so so I've
modified my my response to this question
since I first asked it and that is that
you know both are probably real but they
are really different sprang geofront
plate I think they are aberrant they're
different and sprained you from a
leaflet are really natural there these
are unstressed those are stressed I mean
this organism doesn't like to live on a
plate it really is over evolutionary
time is a parasite pathogen and it has a
very significant phenotype associated
with those differences so what are the
implications of this the major one I
think is that we need to investigate
proteins if we're interested in
investigating proteins are involved in
pathogenicity here to look at those that
are uh pregnant in plant or not that are
upregulated in the plate because there
is such a huge difference and we can
avoid this
description I'll describe here again 20
years ago in the plant cell resistance
of nicosia an event Ammiano to
Phytophthora infestans is mediated by
the recognition of the elicitor protein
in form what the others had done was to
take isolate or clonal lineage us one
they determined it was not pathogenic on
invent bentham iana they saw us in
foreign and then they got pathogen is
what they didn't say is that this I slit
had been on place for about 20 years
it was dramatically different from
anything that appeared in this field at
the same time we were actually doing a
little work on that ourselves in this
very August Journal plant disease and
the papers title was host-pathogen
interactions with PNP and festoons and
the solanaceous host calibrachoa hybrid
s Latonia times hybrid Nkosi an event
damiana all of these hosts were
susceptible to p intestines they all
produced influence so influent is
certainly not the reason that an actual
enoch oceania bintan yana is not
resistant to Phytophthora infestans
so this study is essentially irrelevant
to anything that happens in the field
and i have to guarantee you that there
is not a single spur engine from a
plaint
that is involved in a natural infection
or a number to me there is not one one
could look at targets such as these
these two are XLR effectors were very
highly expressed in leaflets projec
impaired two plates per inch and there
were many other genes that were really
up regulated and least leaflets francha
compared to place for angio so this is
my final slide there are at least two
versions of this organism and maybe more
what's important is that you need to
know which is which and and i identify
that
unfasten a that P infestans can sense
its environment with us and this sensing
its environment really affects the
phenotype which is really I think if you
interested in actually what might happen
in as a disease causing organism and I
think that's important to know and it is
also true that if you do work only with
lab cultured strains you could get
misleading results the question I have
is what about other Hemi by ultros you
know is this phenomenon restricted to P
infestans or it might it apply to other
I mean bio tropes I think I suspect it
does not apply to number troughs I think
there's no way it could apply to
obligate parasites but to hemi bios i
think there's a chance that others might
have this same phenomenon with that I'll
stop and I want to thank you all for
being here I'm not going to thank any
funding organizations because I didn't
get any funding for this and
particularly I want to mention Kevin
right here he's done a lot hillary matin
has been a fantastic support all these
years Sean Atif it was his master's
thesis that I showed you the work on
Margo Bechtel had published the work on
Nkosi Anna Bentham iana and Pallas
Oologah
was a co collaborator and the proposals
that were not funded through our funding
sources so with that I'll stop it if
there are any questions I'd be happy to
answer them Gary you're contrasting
growth of the organism plates the lab
and plants in the field did you ever
look at plants in controlled environment
growth chain is that thinking is there
something about the feel now whatever
the leaflets can be either from the
yield or from the greenhouse and we so
the question was is there something
about plants growing the field that
might have an impact on these results I
actually think there could be but we but
we the difference that I'm describing
today is is when the plants were in the
field or in the greenhouse didn't matter
Keith you did the experiment incubating
the enacted in the plants at greater
than 20 degrees for you were in the
image of being in direct termination but
was the germination phenotype at that
temperature we did not look at that yes
what were them spreadsheet works from
the plate even Germany any frequency
comparable to you so the question that
Keith asked was when we did the
experiment at 21 degrees did we look at
the phenotype of this Franzia as they
were on the leaves and we did not do
that then you measured the amount that
was on the plant at the end of that
infection you know keep going like are
those now at the leaflet stage or are
they still residual II plate spray so
the question is do sporangia maintain
their phenotype through repeated
passages through a plan I think right we
don't know that was a question one of
the reviewers asked as well and as a
it's a great question but I really
wanted to get this paper published so
any others so the question was how did
our finding of these results affect the
way plants are bred for resistance I
think the best answer to that is that
those resistances that were sort of snow
on stresses that were detected in the
lab we could not detect in the field and
I think that's because this branch are
so very different so I think readers
want neat they put their plants out in
the field
they don't suffer the problem that some
would suffer if they never put a plant
out in the field so so I think if you
use leaflet sporangia I think you text
real differences if you use only place
Franchi I think you'll miss those
nuanced differences yes what you like to
say that so this represents what you're
what people observe or are working with
with plate produced sporangia is
essentially an aberrant sort of
regulatory program that doesn't reflect
nature so and and one way to think about
it too is yes yeah okay thank you
I know you would but but what another
way to think about all this is the shift
from the bio trophic to the necro genic
phase which appears to be occurring
earlier with the plate grown scramjet
right okay yeah okay yes so the question
is are the spread shift from the plate
genetically different from the leaflets
brand here I think they're exactly
genetically identical but their gene
expression their state is really
different
correct so the environment these
branches respond to the environment and
what we see the phenotype is result of
that response to the environment
yes how does one ask for questions from
Geneva are there questions from Geneva I
think not okay well thank you very much
I as you can see I'm kind of interested
in this I appreciate you coming this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at Cornell edu